Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis has put himself
in somewhat of a pickle, a conundrum,
a difficult situation, and I want to talk about
that now. He because he got prominent being the
culture war guy, the work work, work, work, CRT
guy, anti work, work, work, I should say CRT guy.
Florida is where wealth goes to. You know
who I'm talking about that Ron DeSantis. He
became a big conversation item for running for
president, possibly challenging Trump in the
2024 presidential primary. And he leaned into
and he's made clear with all of his actions,
his tour and all that, that it's
something he's planning on doing.
But now it's seeming like not a great idea. And I
want to show you before we discuss further. Sarah
Longwell on MSNBC talking about how he kind
of now is forced to go ahead and just run.
But and we'll discuss this more a second. It's
not really a it's not a good time for him to run,
but he kind of has to, which is fascinating.
Speaker 5: What do you think the chances are
that Sanders decides not to run? Well, I don't
think he can decide at this point not to run.
He's effectively already in the race. This really
is his moment. Yes, he's a young guy. But if he,
you know, he's positioned himself really
as a fighter. And if he bows out of this
particular fight, he will never get that
reputation back. And the fact is, right now,
there is a big chunk of the party. You know, I
do focus groups every week with Trump voters.
There's a big chunk of the party that is decent,
is curious, and that wants to move on from Donald
Trump. But Robert Santos is going to have to
figure out, you know, who he's playing to in
this primary. He's sort of decided for some reason
that he's trying to out Trump Trump with the base.
And I think that's a mistake. I think he should be
trying to consolidate these sort of move on from
Trump voters and trying to to really, you know,
build relationships with them and build a broad
enough coalition that he can start getting these
numbers back. And he can't do this thing where
he decides to be sort of a supporting player
in the drama around Donald Trump's indictment,
where he's now out there defending Trump,
he's going to have to figure out a different
strategy than that if he wants to be effective.
Speaker 1: Yes. So what makes it hard for him
to not run now is, number one, as you noted, if
he's branding himself as fighter and all of that,
but then he gets scared away by Trump. And it
was obviously it was obvious he was going to run,
but then he decides not to. And it's clear why
that doesn't look great. But more importantly,
he's already taking the political attacks and
the damage from Trump because Trump identifies
him as a challenger and an enemy. And so he's
getting the negatives of being attacked by Trump,
but not the possible benefit of being
successful in a primary. But then if he
does end up running now that the indictment
has happened and as she was talking about.
He is being a supportive character in his
story and his indictment and all of that.
There's no way a kind of I'm sort of the Trump
without baggage and I can out trump Trump on
vaccines. Maybe I can be more anti-vax than
him and more anti woke than him. But also
I'm supportive of his dishonest narratives in all
these different areas, including the indictment.
That's not going to work. When Trump's one of
the candidates being a Trump 2.0, when Trump is
one of the candidates and they can just pick
the original is definitely not a successful.
Strategy. Now, would it work for anyone to try to
consolidate the non Trump vote? I don't know. Is
there enough anti-Trump vote within the Republican
Party to even make that possible or enough anti
plus people who like Trump but want to move on
from him because a younger generation or someone
with that baggage? I don't think so. I think the
majority of the GOP is still on Trump's side,
but that probably would be a better strategy than
just, Hey, I'm like him, but a little better,
a little younger and a little less baggage. Um,
and the attacks keep coming from Trump here on
True Social. Ron DeSantis is a young man who is
not doing well against me in the polls. That is
true. Sanders is doing much worse these days,
to put it mildly. I believe that if he decides
to run for president, which will only hurt
and somewhat divide the Republican Party,
he will lose the cherished and massive MAGA vote
and never be able to successfully run for office
again if he remains governor, which is what
Florida voters assumed, it would be. A whole
different story. Just saying. But you know, he
has such different moods under social as either.
Speaker 5: Oh right. And Sanders is the.
Speaker 1: Worst and maybe he was a groomer.
Look at this. A photo or just a thought, You
know, maybe he shouldn't run. But you do. You.
But the Trump versus DeSantis saga is one
I've been definitely enjoying watching,
and we will continue to watch it